people are really upset at Mr Beast
right now for making a video where he
cured a thousand people of their
blindness and they're accusing him of
taking advantage of other people's
suffering for his own Prophet my quick
take on this is I'm with Mr Beast I
think what he did was great for a couple
reasons one he helped a thousand people
not be blind anymore this is a surgery
that only takes 10 minutes that cost
thirty five hundred dollars and he paid
for all of them to have the surgery and
they are not blind anymore for a
thousand people I think that's pretty
awesome two he's raised awareness
for the issue and now is a conversation
people are talking about it because of
the video that he made and then three
look at any charity that's out there
look at United Way or whatever charity
you love the most go to their home page
see how they're selling uh sponsorships
and raising donations off of stories
it's off of stores
I think Mr Beast did a great job what do
you think let me know